>>> TOPPING OUR POLITICS LEAD ON
THIS THURSDAY, ONE OF WASHINGTON
STATE'S NEWEST MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS RAN ON A FAMILIAR
MESSAGE.
REDUCE GOVERNMENT REGULATIONS,
GET TOUGH ON CRIME.
WHILE THOSE MIGHT
STEREOTYPICALLY SOUND LIKE
REPUBLICAN CAMPAIGN PLATFORM
POINTS, MARIE GLUESENKAMP PEREZ
IS A DEMOCRAT AND TOUGH TO
PIGEONHOLE.
IN A SOLIDLY RED DISTRICT SHE
ALSO PUT ABORTION RIGHTS AT THE
FOREFRONT OF HER CAMPAIGN AS
WELL AS REDUCING THE COST OF
CHILD CARE.
SHE NARROWLY BEAT A
TRUMP-ENDORSED ARMY VETERAN AND
ELECTION DENIER, JOE KENT, IN
WHAT THE NATION CALLS "THE
BIGGEST UPSET OF THE 2022
MIDTERMS."
CONGRESSWOMAN-ELECT MARIE
GLUESENKAMP PEREZ JOINS US NOW.
CONGRESSWOMAN-ELECT, FIRST OF
ALL, CONGRATULATIONS.
SECOND OF ALL, I WANTED TO HAVE
YOU ON BECAUSE I READ THAT
INTERVIEW IN "THE NATION," WHICH
IS REALLY INTERESTING.
DEMOCRATS TRADITIONALLY DO NOT
DO WELL IN RURAL DISTRICTS.
WHAT MADE YOUR CAMPAIGN
DIFFERENT AND HOW CAN OTHER
RURAL DEMOCRATS HOPEFULLY APPLY
THAT TO THEIR CAMPAIGNS IN THE
FUTURE?
>> WELL, ONE OF THE CRITICAL
DIFFERENCES IS MY BIOGRAPHY.
I LIVE IN A RURAL DISTRICT.
I LIVE IN RURAL TIMBER COUNTY.
I WORK IN THE TRADES.
I OWN AN AUTO REPAIR MACHINE
SHOP WITH MY HUSBAND.
YOU KNOW, WE'RE A SMALL
BUSINESS.
LIKE YOU SAID, WE'VE BEEN BROKEN
INTO FOUR TIMES.
HAD ANOTHER BREAK-IN YESTERDAY.
AND I THINK THAT REALLY CONNECTS
WITH AMERICANS.
LIKE WE JUST WANT A CONGRESS
THAT WORKS AGAIN.
WE WANT A CONGRESS THAT LOOKS
LIKE AMERICA, THAT UNDERSTANDS
WHAT IT'S LIKE TO TRY TO RUN A
SMALL BUSINESS IN THIS ECONOMY.
AND MAKE A PLACE FOR THE TRADES.
>> DO YOU THINK, SPEAKING OF
YOUR MACHINE SHOP BEING BROKEN
INTO, DO YOU THINK THAT TOO MANY
NATIONAL DEMOCRATS ARE TOO
DISMISSIVE OF THE CONCERNS OF
AMERICAN CITIZENS WHEN IT COMES
TO CRIME, POINTING AT STATISTICS
AND TELLING THEM THEY'RE NOT
EXPERIENCING WHAT THEY'RE
EXPERIENCING?
>> YEAH, I THINK THAT'S A FATAL
FLAW IN THE DEMOCRATIC STRATEGY,
IS PEOPLE ARE ALWAYS TRYING TO
EXPLAIN THINGS TO PEOPLE.
THEY'RE OBSESSED WITH BEING
RIGHT ALL THE TIME.
AND I THINK THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
TO UNDERSTAND THE UNDERLYING
FEELINGS AROUND AN ISSUE AND NOT
JUST THE STATISTICS BECAUSE
THOSE STATISTICS, UNLESS YOU
UNDERSTAND THE FACTS ON THE
GROUND, THOSE STATISTICS CAN
SOMETIMES BE HOLLOW.
>> YOU BEAT YOUR OPPONENT,
REPUBLICAN JOE KENT, BY ONLY
2600 VOTES YESTERDAY.
DESPITE BEING AN ELECTION LIAR,
HE FINALLY CONCEDED AFTER THE
RECOUNT.
ARE YOU CONFIDENT YOU CAN
REPRESENT A HISTORICALLY RED
DISTRICT, ESPECIALLY WITH SO
MANY PEOPLE IN YOUR DISTRICT
WILLING TO PUT ASIDE THE FACT
THAT HE WAS AN ELECTION LIAR AND
VOTE FOR HIM.
IT WAS PRETTY CLOSE.
>> YEAH.
YOU KNOW, I'M HERE TO REPRESENT
EVERYONE, NOT JUST THE PEOPLE
WHO VOTED FOR ME.
I THINK WE HAVE A LOT OF SHARED
INTERESTS.
LIKE I SAID, WE ALL WANT A
COUNTRY THAT WORKS AGAIN.
WE WANT OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR
KIDS.
I'M PART OF THE GENERATION THAT
WORK AS HARD AS I WANT, I'M NOT
GOING TO MAKE AS MUCH MONEY AS
MY PARENTS.
I THINK WE'RE SEEING AN
INCREASING I GUESS
DISENCHANTMENT, YOU KNOW, WITH
THE WAY THINGS ARE WORKING FOR
FOLKS.
I'M RUNNING ON REALLY BREAD AND
BUTTER ISSUES OF RIGHT TO REPAIR
LAWS ARE SOMETHING CRITICAL TO
ME AND ONE OF THE THINGS I'LL BE
WORKING HARD TO PASS IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT BECAUSE
THAT'S ONE OF THE INTERESTING
THINGS ABOUT YOUR APPEAL IN YOUR
RURAL DISTRICT, THIS RIGHT TO
REPAIR LEGISLATION.
PROBABLY A LOT OF PEOPLE RIGHT
NOW WATCHING THIS DON'T KNOW
WHAT THAT IS.
ESSENTIALLY IT ALLOWS AMERICANS
TO FIX THEIR OWN STUFF FROM CELL
PHONES TO TRACTORS DESPITE
ATTEMPTS BY CORPORATE AMERICA
AND CORPORATIONS INTERNATIONALLY
TO TRY TO STOP THAT.
TELL US MORE ABOUT THAT AND WHY
IT'S SO IMPORTANT IN RURAL
DISTRICTS SUCH AS YOURS.
>> I'M SORRY, JAKE, I
ACTUALLY -- THE INTERNET QUALITY
CUT OUT HERE.
I DIDN'T -- COULD YOU REPEAT
THAT QUESTION?
>> TELL US ABOUT RIGHT TO
REPAIR, WHAT IT MEANS.
>> YEAH.
SO RIGHT TO REPAIR BILLS ARE,
YOU KNOW, WE IN AMERICA ARE OF
THE BELIEF THAT WE CAN FIX OUR
OWN THINGS.
BUT INCREASINGLY THE TERMS OF
SERVICE IN CONTRACTS EXCLUDE
PEOPLE FROM THAT RIGHT.
SO YOU DON'T HAVE THE RIGHT TO
FIX YOUR OWN TRACTOR, YOUR OWN
iPHONE, HOME MEDICAL EQUIPMENT.
SO IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT CARS.
IT'S ABOUT EVERYTHING.
AND WE'RE SEEING FOR INSTANCE
BMW NOT HAVING DIP STICKS IN
THEIR CARS ANYMORE.
IT'S A DISENFRANCHISEMENT FROM
THE TECHNOLOGY WE RELY ON.
AND I AND MANY, MANY PEOPLE
BELIEVE THAT DIY'S IN OUR DNA.
THE MIDDLE CLASS RELIES ON
THINGS BEING REPAIRABLE AND
MAINTAINABLE.
AND IT FEELS LIKE WE'RE GETTING
SHOVED INTO A CULTURE OF
CONSUMPTION WHERE WE ARE NOT
ABLE TO FIX THE THINGS AND THE
TECHNOLOGY WE RELY ON.
AND I THINK THAT'S A CRISIS FOR
THE MIDDLE CLASS AND FOR
AMERICAN CULTURE.
>> DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSWOMAN-ELECT FROM
WASHINGTON STATE MARIE
GLUESENKAMP PEREZ, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
LET US KNOW